NARRATOR: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT Opencourseware
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT Opencourseware
at ocw.mit.edu.
GUEST SPEAKER: That's it.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE
(ON PHONE): I'm
sorry that I couldn't be there.
Can you guys hear me?
GUEST SPEAKER: Yes.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE
(ON PHONE): OK, guys,
sorry that I couldn't
be there in person.
I'm in California
at this workshop,
and [INAUDIBLE] this panel.
But you guys are doing a great
job, and I think [INAUDIBLE]
last meeting.
I think this is important
to carry on [INAUDIBLE]
to as judges, and Steve,
and [? Ray ?] [? Fayan ?]
and everybody, thanks for
coming in and being judges.
And I guess Roderick
will coordinate with them
to get the information, and
try to [INAUDIBLE] on there.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE
(ON PHONE): OK.
Good.
GUEST SPEAKER: Thanks.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE (ON
PHONE): I'm hanging up,
and I have to run to
my conference now.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK.
Bye.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE
(ON PHONE): Bye.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK,
so tomorrow we'll
have class in the
regular classroom, 34301,
same time, 10:00 to 12:00.
There will be
course evaluations,
so your change to tell
us how you actually
felt about the course,
and what you liked
and what you didn't like.
Afterwards, we'll have an awards
ceremony for the winning team.
You will get some prizes,
and you'll get some cake.
And then that will take
us to around 11:00,
11:30, at which time we'll
come back to [? Scoglin, ?] the
seventh floor lounge.
We'll have pizza and more
food for you guys to enjoy.
So thank you, and
see you tomorrow.